foreign
[Music]
are for the rest of us
um and I'm here to talk to you about
starting a business with r
but here's the thing I never actually
intended to start my own business and to
show you how unintentional my path to
doing what I do now has been let me give
you a brief story
in 2015 I was working my last nine to
five job
my wife had just started a job at the
time it was a pretty challenging job but
she likes challenging jobs
at the time we were hoping uh to have
kids so we were Overjoyed when we found
out that she was pregnant with not one
but two kids we were gonna have twins
uh now at the time we talked about what
to do I really like kids I used to be an
elementary school teacher so we decided
that I would stay home with our kids and
she would continue working
now
for those of you who have kids uh you
might not be surprised to hear that my
pre-kid vision of what being a full-time
stay-at-home dad would be like was
pretty different from the post-kid
reality and so after a few months my
wife very kindly said to me you know
it's okay if this isn't going to quite
work out the way we we imagined it might
um what happened though at the same time
was that the challenging job that my
wife Rachel had started actually came to
feel untenable
um having young kids and an incredibly
challenging job was just a bit too much
and she ended up leaving that job so in
a few months we had gone from having two
jobs and zero kids to having zero jobs
and two kids
and it was at that time I realized okay
I need to to do something to to bring in
a little income for our family so I
started doing some uh freelance data
analysis work I was an Excel user at the
time I used Excel for everything but I
got a little bit bored and I had heard
about R and I'd heard that R could you
know do some nice stuff automate things
make nice dataviz and I was like okay
cool let me learn that
I taught myself R and in the process
realized first of all that I really
liked it and second of all that there
were a lot of people like me who also
wanted to learn are
and so it was from that experience that
I started R for the rest of us
today are for the rest of us does both
education work we have online courses uh
trainings for organizations as well as
Consulting work and I'm going to use
examples from our business
but this isn't really ultimately a talk
about my business this is a talk about
your business
I'm going to focus mostly on marketing
on how to sell your work and the reason
why is it's the thing that people who
are thinking about starting their own
business ask me the most they say David
I want to start my own business but I
have no idea how to find clients how did
you do it
and
I know there are some people potentially
in the room maybe you're waiting for the
next talk who are thinking you know what
I don't actually want to start my own
business
before you run for the doors I think the
reason you might consider staying is
that marketing matters even if you're
just working uh if even if you are
working for someone else so you need to
for example sell your own work within
your own organization so your boss or
your co-workers see what you're capable
of maybe you're making an r package and
you want to get it out into the world
you need to Market it so rather than put
our heads in the sand and not do any
marketing let's learn how to do
marketing well
a quick question if you would say that
you like marketing would you go ahead
and raise your hand
so I see a handful maybe like 10 Max
not that many people in in the room I
would say overall say they enjoy
marketing and I think the reason why is
this
technical People Like Us tend to be
pretty allergic to marketing
and I know that because I in the past
very much felt like this we think okay
if I write really good code that should
be enough I shouldn't have to go out and
sell it right
what I've realized is that what another
thing I've come to realize in the last
few years is that when people say that
they don't like marketing
the marketing they're they're thinking
of is often kind of like this right like
think about stuff you've seen on social
media with a ton of hashtags linked to
who knows where trying to sell who knows
what right like that type of like sleazy
marketing but what I've come to realize
in running are for the rest of us is
that marketing can actually look more
like this can look like education it can
look like teaching and so I think when
you do marketing well it doesn't
actually even necessarily seem like
marketing
let me give some examples from other
people who run kind of Consulting
businesses of how they talk about
marketing and ways that that their
approach also shows up in what we do
with our for the rest of us
so Paul Meiners was asked how he does
marketing how he finds his clients he's
a consultant who trains on like Asana
and pipedrive the details don't really
matter but what he said is the way I do
marketing is simple
I go to where my ideal clients are
and I'm hopeful
and so with Arthur the rest of us what
that's meant
is we go to where people are which
probably won't be a huge surprise for
folks here is Twitter that's where the
art community tends to to show up
and the way we're helpful is every day
for the last three and a half years we
have tweeted out one tip every day at 7
30 a.m
um sometimes things that we create
oftentimes things that other people
create
and so we through doing that we've we've
been able to build up a following of
over 15 000 followers which becomes
useful in ways I'll talk about shortly
West boss talks about his approach being
this share your knowledge for free
with no strings attached
on the art for the rest of us website we
have a Blog there are a bunch of posts
um this is an example of one on how to
set up git and GitHub if you're working
with r and I wrote it first of all
because I it was something I struggled
with so I figured other people probably
would as well
people can go on the art for the rest of
us website can read this for free they
don't have to pay us anything
um and and I'm totally fine with that I
want to give that value
and the thing with offering things for
free
is that I know this is taken from Adam
wadham who says that giving away your
work for free is like compressing a
spring
and that spring releases when you
finally have something up for sale
so rather than thinking about marketing
is going out and saying hey I'm selling
this I'm selling that
it's much better if you can go out and
offer value offer things for free and
once you get that Goodwill hopefully get
some following as well then you can
offer things that are that are paid so
this is an email that I send out twice a
year announcing the start of a program
called R in three months where we do
um a training thing a three-month
training program for folks
and when I send that out because we've
built up that Goodwill because we've
offered things for free people are more
more interested in signing up
I'm going to now offer kind of four
lessons that have been really useful for
me in thinking about how to find clients
so if we think about okay marketing done
well generally looks like kind of
Education
what are some more specific ways that we
can look for clients
so the first lesson that I'm going to
offer is to think about going deep
not Broad
so
people will sometimes say to me hey I
really like what you're doing you know I
love I like teaching too like I'd love
to start a business training people to
learn are
and they'll say and I'll ask you know
okay great like who are you thinking
about trying to to work with and say
well anybody
but here's the problem if you try to
speak to everyone
no one will listen your message is just
too General and people don't it it's not
going to resonate if it's overly General
so instead what you really want to do is
find your people in in business speak
people will talk about niching down
finding a niche that you can work in
and so with our for the rest of us even
the name of the business was that was
like my first attempt to kind of Niche
down I'm not necessarily trying to train
everybody I'm training the rest of us
now of course everybody interprets that
slightly differently but generally
speaking what I think of as our kind of
Ideal audience is people who want to
learn are but are intimidated by it and
and I pitch everything to that specific
audience
on marketing emails that go out in the
footer of those emails
this is what the text says I think you
know what an R user look looks like I'm
probably not what you have in mind
not a hardcore Quant I won't jump on you
for any small mistake and I want to help
others avoid the pain and you can see
through this language I am trying to
identify the this is the type of person
that I think are for the rest of us is
best for it's not that other people
couldn't like any I think anybody can
learn R through the materials that we
offer but this is really like our ideal
audience and so for some people that's
not going to resonate and that's okay
but for other people that really will
resonate and they'll be inclined to work
to to learn R through US whereas a more
General framing probably wouldn't appeal
to them
in addition to turning people on having
language that speaks to certain people
it's really important also to turn
people off and I know that sounds
counterintuitive because you think well
you want to have an offering that's
going to be you know like applicable to
anybody
but it actually doesn't work very well
um and turning people off is a really
effective strategy to help you identify
the niche that you do want to work in
uh so I'm in the process of writing a
book it's called are without statistics
which is my attempt to both say what the
book is but also what it's not it's
broadly speaking a book about kind of
quirky interesting things that you can
do with r that don't involve any complex
statistics so when I tweeted about this
in March
I got this feedback
um Luis wrote marketing tip the label
will create a huge barrier among
statisticians and Scholars
and I put this up not in any way to
disparage these like I really appreciate
the feedback
but the thing is
that's not my target audience
statisticians and Scholars are I mean
maybe they'll read the book I'm I'm more
than happy for them to read the book but
that's not the audience that I'm going
for and by calling it are without
statistics I'm intentionally trying to
turn some people on but also turn some
people off
lesson two uh focus on results
so it's really easy for those of us who
are technical to get really into the
tools that we use you know we want to
talk about this new package or this new
function that I learned for clients
though what they really care about is
getting to the goal
as an example of this a couple two or
three years ago a potential client came
to us from the state of Connecticut
and they said David we have to produce
169 reports one for each town in the
state of Connecticut we we use Excel we
have no idea how this is going to work
I've heard that R can maybe do this in
my head what I'm thinking is yeah of
course like our markdown parameterized
reporting and page down package but
that's not at all what I'm going to say
to them instead I'm going to frame it as
yeah we can help you to automate this we
can do it more efficiently and we'll
also do it in a way that there will be
fewer copy paste errors they care about
that end result they don't care about
the tools generally that that we're
using so we did that report and this is
what we ended up producing entirely with
the the tools that I talked about
on the art for the rest of us website on
the Consulting page the headline is
communicate more effectively and
efficiently note that I'm not talking
about any R packages anything like that
I'm talking about how to communicate
effectively and efficiently which is
language that I think will resonate with
my clients and potential clients
lesson three is to make your client the
hero it's really easy when you're
developing marketing materials early on
to say I can do this I can do that but
really the way you want to position
yourself is as the guide that is helping
your client but the client Remains the
hero of the story
um so this is a report we did in 2020
maybe 2021 on census Outreach efforts in
the in the 2020 census and when I write
about this I have a case study on the r
for the rest of us website here's what I
say the 52 reports helped auras impact
in the Democracy funders Network that
was our client to achieve their goals
and more
and they did this without the agonizing
manual work so I'm talking about I'm
framing it in a way that I think will
resonate with potential new clients and
I'm framing the client here as the hero
not saying you know we we did this I'm
saying we helped them to make these
reports without that agonizing manual
work
last lesson is this
relationships matter more than technical
skills
when you're starting out it's really
easy to think you know I just gotta like
tweak this one bit of CSS on my website
to be honest that doesn't really matter
that much when you first start out
because your first clients are almost
certainly going to come from people you
know
at the same time that you cultivate
existing relationships it's important to
cultivate new relationships so for me
what this often looks like is I'll see
people tweet about art for the rest of
us
and I'm really grateful when they do of
course it's like fantastic marketing for
me so I'll follow up with them and I'll
say you know thank you for doing that I
really appreciate that and I'll do
something like give them a free course
and so by doing that you know I make a
hopefully cultivate a good relationship
but then also maybe this person signs up
for another course or are in three
months or mentions it to a colleague I
think it can lead to other things in the
future
so to wrap up
I want to leave you
um with this idea you are not me
I've given examples here
um and I've drawn lessons from the work
of art for the rest of us
but it's really important to focus not
so much on the specific tactics that
we've used rather focusing on the larger
lessons as an example if you were
thinking about becoming a consultant
working with data science teams you'd
probably talk more about the technical
side of things than we tend to but you
still want to do it in a way that frames
the conversation around the end result
as opposed to an over emphasis on the
the technical tools themselves
so I hope I have left you with the idea
that it is possible to sell your work
without selling your soul
[Applause]
[Music]